[Music]
hey what is going on YouTube now there's
a lot to be said about this topic and in
all honesty we're just gonna go ahead
and get into it there are three major
events that happen in the past week
that's a little bit hard to look over
we're talking about alton sterling
falando castile and the sniper shootings
in dallas that all have to do with a
singular but very complicated topic now
i touched on this topic just last week
and it's crazy that [ __ ] like this is
coming up again in case you don't know
what's going on let's go through a quick
refresher let's talk about the first
event alton sterling a man who sold cd's
and dvd's outside a convenience store
was murdered by two cops now i didn't
say take him down
I said murdered if you watch this video
you can go ahead and form your own
opinions reportedly a homeless man had
an altercation with him and reported
that Alton Flash's gun at him so he
called the cops
so yes Alton did have a gun on him Alton
then asked what he did wrong
which proceeds to him getting taken down
and pasted and held to the floor in the
video footage you'll see a cop yelling
that he has a gun and then they execute
the man plain and simple and once again
yes Alton did have a gun eyewitnesses
stated that he did not reach for his gun
and then it was still in his pocket and
he simply asked what he did wrong so now
let's talk about the facts now what we
did see from this video is that after
one cop had a gun to his chest and
another to his face they unloaded on him
they went up to his dying body and
pulled the gun straight out of his
[ __ ] pocket now all this sterling if
you guys do read the multiple articles
out there yes he was a previous
convicted felon so no he is not supposed
to have a gun however that is not a
death sentence now let's talk about
falando Castille now he's a man who was
pulled over for a broken taillight and
was murdered by an officer the officer
asked if he knew he had a broken
taillight and he said no and then he was
asked to put his hands in the air
along with his girlfriend the officer
then asked for his license and
registration he lets him know that it's
in his right side back pocket letting
the officer also know he has a firearm
on him his girlfriend then lets the
officer know that he is licensed to
carry meaning that he has a license to
carry a firearm he reaches for the bat
pocket
as already told to the officer then the
officer proceeds to unleash bullets onto
his body killing him now let's talk
about the sniper shooting in Dallas this
is something that by this time the video
comes out you know I'm not going to know
too much about but let's talk about some
of the facts the murder of the police
officers were racially charged and this
horrible event happened during a protest
in light of Castile and Sterling's death
before being taken down the sniper
Michael Johnson a member of the US Army
Reserve told the negotiator he was upset
about the black lives matters protest
and he was also a set at white people
and that he wanted to kill specifically
white officers now that all of you are
caught up on this and we got the facts
out the way let's talk about this there
are a few things that are going through
my mind aside from being outraged pissed
off sad and disappointed number one
there needs to be accountability one of
the biggest reasons in my opinion to why
so many people are upset is based on the
fact there is no [ __ ] accountability
officers who are human who are prone
like every other person out there to
[ __ ] up are not being held accountable
for their actions people are finding out
that if you have a badge suddenly you
are untouchable that if you murder
someone in broad [ __ ] daylight with
evidence and footage you will not be
held accountable for your actions people
are finding out there is no justice in
their justice system how sad is it cops
and officials who know in their hearts
that their fellow officers are wrong
will not speak up about it
[ __ ] your blue veil a good cop who
apparently are the majority of officers
out there will not hold their peers
accountable for their actions and that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] officers and government
officials if you will not do it then who
will and that is a question to be asked
who who do you think will be up in arms
if the color of a man's skin is going to
determine whether they get a bullet in
them or if they get to see their family
that night number two people are
apathetic and complacent to the [ __ ]
up things in this Justices you may not
know it but from the excuses and reasons
that I've heard from people shows how
complacent people are when it comes to
the problem now
mind you I used to be like this as well
too for instance people have said if he
didn't ask what he was being arrested
for it he wouldn't have died because he
was resisting arrest this is already
[ __ ] up and let me tell you why by
saying that you are also saying that
anybody who asked an officer what they
did wrong before being apprehended is
reason enough to be shot and we are okay
with that so I want you to stop and
reassess what you're going to say before
you say that statement and tell me how
the [ __ ] is that the norm number three
there needs to be a process of healing
and the issue needs to be properly
addressed without violence now we as a
society and as a people need to fight
against injustice that right there is is
fact enough as it is without segregation
[Music]
number three there number three there
needs to be a process of healing and the
issue needs to be properly addressed
without violence now we are society and
as people need to fight against
injustice without segregation right now
it has become an us-versus-them
situation and nothing is going to come
of this going up on a rooftop sniping
officers because you hate white cops
doesn't bring about a solution and
doesn't begin to help the process of
healing personally I think people need
to stop looking at situations of police
brutality and racial profiling as people
complaining about nothing and look at it
as a real problem I'm just gonna use
this as a quick example how many times
have we heard someone say why say black
lives matter when all lives matter
listen you dumb [ __ ] that's what black
lives matter means it means that until
people of color are seen as something
more in second-class citizens and
criminals then we will not be on par
with everyone else
thus meaning all lives matter and to be
honest with you if you still don't
understand this concept after I just
broke it down in layman's terms then
you're not a [ __ ] idiot
number four we need to be careful about
how we take in media information and I
am responsible for this as well the way
the media is pushing out content about
situations such as this is not helping
yes it brings light to the situation but
we also have to know how that
information is being given to us and why
people you have to realize news outlets
and etc could give a [ __ ] less about the
content they push out unless it gives
them a store so for me I feel that if
the world burns due to their information
it doesn't matter unless there's a story
to be told if we are going to use media
we should use media as a way to bring
awareness but be smart about the
information that we digest simply put
for me all this [ __ ] is not mean this is
not something that surprises me at all
it is something that has been a long
time coming there are leaders and we as
a country need to find a [ __ ]
solution everyone needs to address and
recognize that police brutality racial
profiling and an unfair and unjust
justice system exist period it is not a
[ __ ] myth and as a [ __ ] fact a man
was murdered execution-style in front of
eyewitnesses and the officers are saying
it was just a man reached for his
license and registration as requested
and was murdered in front of his
girlfriend and four-year-old child
officers were murdered due to a constant
push on media of police brutality and
rising racial tensions that has forced
down our throats by the media every day
so let's start an intellectual and
progressive conversation right here let
me ask you guys this what more do you
need
how many more Trayvon Martin's Eric
Gardner's how many more of these cases
need to be shown and highlighted for us
to actually give a [ __ ] about this
problem and to admit that it is an issue
so if government officials won't
recognize it and the people that are
supposed to serve and protect us won't
admit to it that what do we as a people
do how can we bring a solution about to
this problem without segregation and
doing it in a positive way what do you
think we should do what is the solution
to this problem
you
[Music]
[Music]